in liberia's capital monrovia a march to
sweep corruption out of the country
hundreds of people gathered with brooms
in their hands for a small protest
against a big problem corruption is
everywhere says esther thompson she says
she has to pay bribe to get her children
in school to get money out of her bank
account or even to get a job but it's
even worse in government
in the house of senate in the house of
representatives in government that's
where corruption is
in august three senior figures of
whereas government were suspended after
the u.s treasury imposed sanctions
against them the president's chief of
staff is accused of corruption and
directing warlords to threaten political
rivals the managing director of the port
authority is accused of funneling money
into private accounts and the state
solicitor general is accused of
shielding suspected criminals blocking
investigations into government
corruption
the government denies any wrongdoing
that those sanctions were not because of
the government was not targeted at the
president so if people are using these
things to gain political relevance well
we're in a democracy our citizens are
allowed to protest and do as they feel
but the truth is that we've done more as
a government than any other
administration in trying to fight graph
in the public space
these protesters are marching not
towards the presidential palace or
parliament but towards the u.s embassy
they're hoping the u.s can do what their
government has failed to arrest and
prosecute those stealing public funds
hundreds not thousands of people came
out to demonstrate against corruption
not the numbers that
organizers had hoped for but they say
they have the backing of the liberian
people it's just that there is here in
this country a culture of fear when it
comes to speaking out against government
corruption
gift lama worked as an auditor at the
liberian revenue authority in october
2020 she was found dead in her car state
investigators concluded miss lama died
of suffocation an accident says the
government a cover-up says lama's
widower there was a state-sponsored
murder
because
my wife was investigating
taxes in the 225 billion u.s allo
paid through the commercial bank
that's supposed to be deposited at the
central bank and will have been diverted
that people inherited already
following miss lama's death president
passed several bills in parliament a
witness protection act to protect those
who expose corruption a code of conduct
for government officials and a
fast-track court to prosecute people
accused of taking bribes
but organizers of the march say that's
not enough they're calling for a change
of political culture to sweep the
country clean of dirty politics bad
governance and corruption
nicholas hawk al jazeera monrovia
liberia